hello guys Ryan right here
I'm Pfeiffer brown Pfeiffer and I she
just realized the coal Arbor same woman
from dear fat people has just released
will not just release recently released
dear black people so she's still going
yeah she's still going I thought after
the fat people think she just moved
no she's capitalizing off the [ __ ] that
she is portraying but she did say well
the likes on this video but she kept the
comments
yikes yikes all right let's see what
dear black people's all like claimed I
used to read Seventeen magazine bunch of
white girls going to prom in the
limousine dear black people that don't
you is what too many of you are having
to say to the [ __ ] up police oh you
thought I was going somewhere else with
that it's kind of racist w to act as my
insurance policy on this video I mean to
join me in this video my friend Latoya
wait girls love black penis they want
the 10th skin they want the weave the
big titties the big end can we please
have our race back says the best with
the blonde hair I see y'all using
pickles at your barbecues on your
hamburgers yeah that's appropriating
Polish culture that even mad at you
cause pimples are [ __ ] delicious can
we just get on this whole appropriation
of black culture thing right now your
[ __ ] is just cooler black girls quit
talk about your nails per second I'm not
trying to appropriate and feel I just
really [ __ ] like
they're long they're gorgeous
encompassing anything they find on your
nail this freckle here is the color of
muscle on your nails with this big how
do you wipe your ass that's you why
that's you that's you trip I see almond
Starbucks that's appropriating
everything that is white and no one
makes fun of you for going Starbucks I'm
like when I go to the jerk chicken place
I'd like some jerk chicken please but
not too spicy
shut up and give me a ginger beer I'm a
white girl I have a very delicate palate
I want to call the spice this was made
for bland foods and then you make more
money than us cuz even when I do the
exact same job as a man I get paid less
money but I don't know anything about
inequality I know that anywhere does
really dollar of like never say any
plebeian people a favor and stop putting
the n-word in the best hip-hop songs I
feel like black people are watching you
in the Quran the wait to see what I'll
do when that word comes I'm the youngest
breath in all night it's so true him
using that words a bit of stretch don't
you think he grew up in the juber hood
little bit started from the upper-middle
now I'm here yeah right it doesn't have
the same ring to because I must go like
the pick and choose which stereotypes
you actually want to keep when I walk by
a black guy I had my purse
cuz he's gonna steal it no no good no
why should we charge Cara typical
[ __ ] when I walk by a black guy I
get like scared that their giant dick is
just gonna like hit me in the arm
you want the stereotype with big dick so
that's that's a good you keep that one
black [ __ ] I know my dad watches my
videos right for sure
you must know you think you want a big
dick but then it's like when you get an
ice cream cone with too many scoops on
it you're just like hella [ __ ] I'm gonna
get this all mmm so you do the only
thing you can do your milks we are done
is she talking about my thing she's
talking about
haha you don't mean all that dick penis
whole bunch of my idols in business and
in light of share are black people the
[ __ ] Kevin Hart he's awesome by the
way isn't be eg racist to make sure if
there was an all-white entertainment
channel y'all lose your [ __ ] true woo
thanks for making country music cool now
that's not real country and you're from
the condo next to me
you ain't country either sure whole lot
of people born in North America with
Jamaican accent what Devon everybody
should be proud where they're from but
you grew up two houses away from me
there's a lot of kids of Jamaicans
pulling a Madonna my new album is a
reflection of how I feel after sucking
the sword at men you've been in London
for three days [ __ ] don't tell me
you're on island time you've never been
to the island you guys are comforting
your own culture [ __ ] you're from the
suburbs you a hug speaking of hurts what
the KKK do and have done in the history
of the world is completely [ __ ] up and
not okay
however they are proof that the white
people invented the goody well pretty
sure you have procreated that weave from
an indian girl why don't we all just
enjoy whatever the [ __ ] we want from
every culture can I ask a question about
Caribana wave then jump or jump in wave
night people
I love the Caribana festival I have so
much fun going there but I was feel very
underrepresented why can't there be the
token white crow float the big-ass big
crashing white girl with the cornrows in
like she was on vacation I feel like
black people for cornrows and white
girls hair as a way to get back at us
for slavery my scalp is burnt and I look
[ __ ] stupid honey cornrows twice a
million pull so hard for the [ __ ]
want to punch you my hair isn't my dress
you don't have to pull so much I know
goddamn slippy white girl hair dye [ __ ]
cray as a way to get back at us for
slavery yes okay yeah let's talk about
slavery it's
was really [ __ ] up but the thing is I
wasn't there I'm [ __ ] sick of hearing
that
I don't know the struggle cuz you're
right I don't
and I'd really like you to explain it to
me so that I can help I'm making jokes
and making light right now because
that's what I do in offer situations but
I find what I see happening to the black
population disgusting black person we go
to jail and his kids would be fatherless
for this but white people can have this
if they have a last saint's this is okay
but this isn't I don't even know how to
pretend that slavery doesn't still exist
because it does it's called minimum wage
and the jail system in America you think
I don't notice when kids don't have a
dad they're gonna act out so why don't
you stop putting people's dad's in jail
for nothing
go hey Bill Nye the Science Guy who if I
ever had an N word it would be him has
recently said that science has proven we
are all actually from the same race and
I think it's about damn time we start
acting like it Thunder said Betty White
says the [ __ ] with the blonde hair
thanks for watching everybody my name is
Nicole Arbour yeah if you like this
video give it a thumbs up share with
your friends and leave a comment below
I really want to hear you guys comments
on this video that's why I do these to
make you laugh at us our conversation
thanks for putting in your random
nonsense was all thanks for having me
that's the way she makes when she's
imitating me [ __ ] you too trick thanks
again for watching and until next time
go team I'm gonna need my kid Latoya
just to [ __ ] people up if ever there's a
time we can stick small animals to your
nails and that is where they will live
you gonna be the first you know what
what I want to hear what you think I'm
gonna get a lot of crap for saying this
we're about to be on different pages go
I liked the video really I thought it
was funny really I feel like she took
the criticism from the dear fat people
stuff one of the top complaints I heard
was she's not making jokes
she's just complaining right she's going
out a way to attack this one she decided
to defend also make some jokes it was
edgy humor but it wasn't like to the
point where I felt like a black person
or a wiper
it's gonna get really offend right now
it's coming from a white person's point
of view of how white people view black
people in kind of uh what's the word for
it wanting to be black kinda way yeah
you know yeah it's like the the PG
version of a white person's take on
black people right maybe stereotypes oh
yeah like this dig yeah the stereotypes
because it wasn't mean it was funny and
honestly like the dear fat people thing
yeah that was mean but when I watched it
I wasn't like oh yeah it was like yeah
that's super [ __ ] but I mean it is I
mean yeah that sucks but I just don't
think that I just don't you know some
people just make you laugh yeah and you
like think she doesn't make I don't I
don't gel with her I love the bit about
you ever have too many ice cream scoops
just compare that to a black penis
that's what she because I've met people
like almost everyone I've met who is
slept with a black guy has said yeah
black people's dicks are huge a lot of
them to say it's kind of hard to put up
hot it's kind of difficult to fully
enjoy because it hurts when it goes
inside and it's too deep in the mouth
sometimes like it's just so so I like
the fact that she was taking a white
purse because there are some people who
just love huge dick but she was taking
like the average white girl perspective
of rights care such a big B right yeah
no I think it would probably be a scary
scary totally hmm
if I'm watching a porno uh-huh and
there's a black penis yeah and if it's
huge usually move on to the next video
really I'm not racist it's just it's
it's like it sounds it's intimidating
you makes you feel bad by yourself it
makes me feel really bad about my me
then when it goes all the way if they go
at all I feel like oh she's getting hurt
because first is intimidating because
yeah black people have huge penises well
at least the ones I love them I can't
say all them that be racist white people
have huge penis is important and it can
freak me out by how big it is that's why
it has nothing to do with the fact that
they're blah it's like if a white guy in
a foreign video how to dick that big
give a freak you know either
like that like why are they designed
that way cuz God had to make up to them
yeah God was oh yeah yeah what was your
purpose and giving them bigger ting do I
needed something in return
woman like when we get the booty mm-hmm
black guys get the [ __ ] what do white
girls get it you guys I've had to suffer
for anything you get respect and the
ability to vote now amen jeez yeah
thought it was funny I'd like to see
some more of her stuff eventually and
see if she can start making me laugh I
honestly feel like I'm ready heard that
a lot of people don't [ __ ] like this
video and it's because they don't like
her all right I didn't know about her
until the dear fat people video what did
she do before the dear fat people know I
never researched I did a video of the
dear fat people one there was a person
with me who was really skinny doing the
video and she was complaining a lot
mm-hmm
and people in the comments were like the
fact I really doesn't care referring to
me oh you're not fat I'm overweight I've
been losing weight five days no sir
they're people every day five days
seriously yeah I'm really proud of you
des come home a lot yeah he he baked
some amazing chicken high high quality
vitamins jeez yeah getting help I'm so
proud of you thank you yeah thank you
yeah but back to her dear black people I
felt like if you keep an open it's kind
of when I feel about Mel Gibson right
now not to compare her to the legacy
that Mel Gibson Milt
it's like Mel Gibson [ __ ] up really
bad
you know like was horrible with some
people yeah now he's trying to redeem
himself and I kind of feel like well
come on let him redeem himself in the
filmmaking business and that's kind of
how I feel about her like she's been
saying she's doing comedy I love you
were like it's not funny you weren't
doing Cohn you're just attacking so I
feel like all the [ __ ] she received
she's trying to apply to eat around
she's trying to be different and I
respect that about her I do too we all
we all we all trip up but trust me I
know there's a lot of you out there who
are gonna hate me for saying that so you
got might even let subscribe because
it's okay hey let him have his opinion
let me have my opinion you're not your
opinion leave them in the comments hmm
comments they're all gonna be nice
charlie not know YouTube do you not know
my channel everyone loves you wait for
the comments on this video stop
seriously yeah not everyone loves me
well who are they didn't judge you for
gosh sakes they are mean 14-year old fat
kids we're calling me fat yeah suck it
anyway guys thanks for tuning in to the
channel if you're new to it you can
subscribe to day and become a reject Oh
bot check out Pfeiffer brown on Facebook
Instagram Twitter
she's an actress going places in the
world so keep a lookout and I caught on
YouTube that you published a video like
four years ago wait have you seen yeah
so check me out on youtube y'all yes I
fir brown years old videos public and
leave really nice comments please yeah
and ask her to make more videos cuz she
could have a good YouTube career all
stop yeah y'all come over and start
following me we can really go places
let's do it
you mean that sounds sexual I didn't
mean it to be sexual sorry Veronica I
always get myself into these situations
where you're friends with the guy and he
has a girlfriend no no no